in these days in bioengineering but i
have a long-standing interest in doing
molecular evolution and phylogenetics so
when i saw i was in that part of the
program and particularly when i saw it
was after tell me i thought that i ought
to make use of this and provide some
sort of continuity and talk about this
so this is actually a problem that i've
been interested in for a very long time
and it's quite connected to some of the
things that tandy was talking about it's
really a problem of trying to model
insertions and deletions
phylogenetically you want to file a
genetic tree
so you know in sessions of deletions are
very rare events um you know they can
help us resolve deep branches in the
tree so often when you try and
reconstruct trees you know at some point
when you go back substitutions max out
and so you have to start looking at
rarer things indels gene fusions and
eventually other things to try and
resolve those deep events in
evolutionary history
and sessions are also enriched for
events of interest and i was like really
infuriated infuriated by this all this
maybe some others were about all this
discourse around suzcof2 when people
were talking about some small amino acid
insertion right and the spike protein
and saying that this is evidence of
skull duggary right you know or whatever
it's like infuriating this is a very
very common thing right that happens in
evolution all the time so
to use this as evidence for some
conspiracy theory really sort of pissed
me off so you know that is a very
isolated example but in fact there's
many examples of the history of history
even from history where you see an
insertion
um it does something phylogenetic and
interesting and it would be interesting
to ask
whether that's significant whether
that's something unusual or you know is
it something that indicates that there
was some kind of selection going on
there
and you know indel rates if you look at
them in alignments proteins genomes
whatever they can be very informative
they can be telling us things about
what's going on in these alignments both
in terms of the structure but also in
terms of things like the lengths of the
indulge right if you see indoles that
are a multiple of three nucleotides in
length in a genome alignment
and they're consistently that way that
suggests that it's in the protein coding
gene it's preserving the reading frame
so i want to say something that's kind
of a blanket statement but i think it's
pretty much justifiable put some data up
there's really no established statistics
for measuring indulge like we have this
very established statistics of you know
ratio of synonymous non-synonymous
substitution rate for example for
looking at signatures of selection in
protein coding genes we basically have
nothing like that for indulge really and
i think arguably this is because indel
rates are very tough to measure and this
is a these are some results that are
quite similar to the benchmark that tani
was showing uh where we basically
simulated some indians on a tree and
then started to realign them
and we were looking in particular
whether you could then use those
reconstructed alignments to measure the
indel rate right just by counting right
counting and dividing so we plotted some
distributions of the ratio of the rate
that we estimated to the true rate and
so there's some posterior probability
variance that sort of comes in there
uh some some variance that comes in just
because you're fixating on a single
alignment you might have got it wrong
and there's stochastic noise in the
alignment so actually that comes in even
if you know the true alignment you get
sort of a bit of noise on on what your
estimate of the indel rate is what we
see is that systematically there's noise
introduced by all of these methods and
um and you know generally speaking the
methods that have some concept of
phylogeny in them in particular if they
have a phytogenetic likelihood they're
going to do better
than the ones that don't have any
concept like that and i don't mean this
is a slam on any particular methods i
would argue that these methods are
mostly trying to get protein structures
right and as the discussion that tiny
and i just had uh i i would suggest that
um that alignments that are built
basically around protein structures are
going to tend to be over alignments
because they're sort of alignments based
on 3d coordinates and if you delete an
amino acid and put it back then it's
going to have roughly the same 3d
coordinates and it's going to look like
it was aligned to the thing that was
deleted before
even though there's no sort of
continuous lineage relating them
anyway so i want to talk a bit about
some of the methods that we use for this
in particular just the the underlying
model of evolution that allows us to
measure insertions and deletions and
really what i would like to go for i
think would be the great goal to get to
here is something that's as robust and
as mathematically reliable as the kinds
of models that we have for modeling
substitutions in sequencing right which
are just these continuous time markov
chains right with a finite number of
states
rates going in between the different
states we can write everything out this
is a we've got an equation of states so
you know there's a probability vector
that changes over time evolves over
times of rate matrix
uh we could solve this with a
matrix exponential
and that gives us the probability of
going from one state to another state
over a finite period of time in this
markov chain right so it's all pretty
straightforward you know we have this
matrix exponential is kind of the key
thing
um you know we also need to specify or
we can often deduce a stationary
distribution actually from this rate
matrix we had either specify an initial
distribution or we can deduce it as as
being a stationary distribution of the
markov chain
so this is very very common
we can in theory do this for sequences
as well as just individual sites right
we our state space
in this version of the model is just
discrete um we haven't said it has to be
finite we could extend this to the set
of all sequences if we wanted in fact
you could make it um continuous state
space as well if you want that's a whole
different area of diffusion equations
and so on but we want to just stick with
the set of finite the set of c all
possible dna sequences that's still a
discrete set it's not it's no longer
finite but it's a discrete set of things
and we can define a model like this on a
set like that so we could just kind of
say what's the rate from going
going from any one sequence x to another
sequence y
um you know and just kind of use some
string algebra to sort of define the
various source and destination states
that we can go from and come to
uh and and we can define substitutions
or point changes
something like this abd goes to acd
we can define deletions a b d goes to a
d we can define insertions a d goes to a
c d and here a b c and d are just
constituent strings that we're
concatenating together and just in know
just specify this model okay great i've
just written down some notation
what this is giving us is sort of a
concrete way to specify the model
but not really taking us very far
towards this goal of trying to solve it
trying to figure out what's the
probability of going from one sequence
to another sequence in a particular
finite time
so that's what i want to get to and
really i think the the best tool for
this
is the idea of some kind of finite state
machine
uh that chews up an input sequence and
spits up an
output sequence okay so it's basically a
sort of a finite state machine model
that will transform an input into an
output and it would be nice to get a
model like this
that somehow is
either an exact
version of
a model like this you know sort of an
evolving continuous time model
that just runs for a finite amount of
time
or it's a close approximation to it so
i'm gonna go for the close approximation
um because it turns out you can't get an
exact solution with a finite state model
um
so you know there is an exactly solved
version of this this this quite
celebrated model from 1991 from thorne
casino and felsenstein often called
abbreviated to the tkf 91 model it's
basically a birth death process on
sequences the reason it's solvable is
because it only allows
uh individual residues to be inserted or
deleted at any one time
so this allows you to partition the
sequence up into a whole bunch of
independent zones and you're sort of
back to an iid type of model where every
sequence is every residue in the
sequence is evolving independently
you can then
derive differential equations to the
fate of individual zones in this
sequence so you know you've got
sequences being deleted at a rate mu
you've got new insertions coming at a
rate lambda to the right of them
uh so this is sort of a birth death
process because these new incisions can
be deleted as well over time and there's
a little bit of coupling between the
ancestral residue and the newly inserted
or deleted residues you can solve this
it's basically
exactly isomorphic to a linear birth
death process with constant immigration
whose immigration rate is the same as
the insertion rate
um so far so good but this breaks down
as soon as you try to get to realistic
models which have deletions that kind of
take out more than one residue at once
because then the different residues in
the sequence become coupled it's no
longer
a sort of independent zones model and
there's a bunch of approximations that
people have tried to do so i should say
pro by the way that when you do solve
this model this gives you a an exact an
exact solution that is a three-state
pair hidden markov model
and by a pair him markov model i just
mean an hmm a hidden markov model that
sort of generates two sequences at once
or we should be more precise and say
it's sort of uh one of the sequences is
an input sequencer transforms an input
into an output and if we're going to be
really precise that's a finite state
transducer as opposed to a finite state
in markov model but they're basically
the same thing
um so we're going to we end up you know
solving the tk 91 model we get a
three-state machine like this with nine
transitions and each of these nine
transition probabilities are analytic
functions of the parameters of the model
this is great so we can actually use
this model to estimate those parameters
by fitting it to observe sequence data
and then various people have tried to
generalize this to the case where there
are longer insertions and deletions
and there's a bunch of these sorts of
approaches and some of them involve well
so so the the model that uh that uh
tandy mentioned uh the barley phi model
is in here it's one of them it's this
riddling sushil model
you know and these are all models that
use various heuristic approximations and
the heuristic approximations amount to
saying things like well what if there
was only one insertion allowed in any
time period or you know what if the this
the solution to the gap probability uh
the gap opening uh penalties and the gap
extension penalties in this alignment
algorithm sort of had a particular form
let's let's
guess at what that form is
they're basically all uh well-informed
educated guesses
um up until this version uh this thing
that was was produced in in 2020 by
nicola demaio
uh which uses a slightly more systematic
physics-inspired approximation which is
about the sort of matching moments of
the gap length distribution
and this is the approach i just want to
talk about um and this is what we've
extended slightly
um so just as context i mentioned that
you can't solve this exactly with a
finite
three-state hidden markov model or even
any finite number of states and uh uh uh
eleanor rivers is sure that he showed
this actually that uh just apparently by
simulation that you know the finite time
gap length distributions in this this
kind of model are not geometrically
distributed
even if
the instantaneous model does have
geometrically distributed indel lengths
what that means is actually is that even
if the infinitesimal model the model
that's happening in any instant of time
is a finite state machine
then once you compound the effect of all
of those instances together and multiply
them all together you end up with a sort
of explosion of states that can no
longer be represented exactly by a
finite state machine
because there's possibilities of one
indel occurring inside another in dell
and then the overlap and the length
distributions become convolved and so on
it's sort of you lose this sort of
simple elegance that you have in the
infinitesimal model once you go to these
these larger models
so demaio then sort of built on this and
said okay well they're not exactly
they're not exactly the same formal
model what happens in an instant time is
not exactly what happens at a finite
time but let's make the approximation
that it is let's say that uh you know
we'll find the best fit model uh where
the gap length distributions can still
be modeled by geometric distributions
which is basically the same as saying
it's a finite state machine you know so
it's a pair hmm
so by doing this he just derived these
um
moment evolution equations
uh but in the somewhat sort of laborious
way where he had to kind of work through
each special case
and he left out some cases because they
became a bit complicated so he left that
one transition in the hmm but i really
enjoyed this approach i thought it was a
huge step forward in this problem that
sort of stopped me for a very very long
time and i think that the field had been
kind of hung up on it
um
it's very similar in spirit to what you
see in physics when you do these sort of
moment evolution type approaches uh
where you basically say well you've got
i've got this very very complex system
and i can't model it exactly but let's
think instead about how the means of
various quantities evolve so the right
things are based on that assumption
so basically i just want to give a very
kind of i i would say this is really a
consolidation of nicola de mayo's ideas
it's somewhat simplified and but i think
it allows you to generalize them a
little bit further the basic idea is
that you've got an infinitesimal model
and a finite time model
we're going to see if we can derive the
finite time model from the infinitesimal
model
and the finite time model is going to be
an approximation and the finite time
model is going to just look like this
we're going to say we stipulate that
it's a three-state pair hmm therefore
it's got nine transitions it's got a
match state and insert state and delete
state match state is an alignment of the
ancestral descendant residue insert
state is a newly added descendant
residue and a delete state involves a
removal of an ancestral residue
and you know we've got these various
transitions that amount to for example
transition b is the transition from an
aligned pair of residues to a newly
inserted descendant this is what you
might think of in classic bioinformatics
algorithms as a gap opening penalty or a
gap opening probability and then all the
other probabilities can be interpreted
similarly
and we want to relate this to what's
happening in an instant of time which is
this infinitesimal generator model
and again this is a three three state
model because we're just thinking now
still of an ancestral or descendant
sequence that can be a line except this
has just happened over an infinite
decimal instant of time
so because it's still infinite decimal
instead of time we never have to worry
about you know seeing more than one
insertional deletion event in this
because by definition in an instant
we're only allowing one event
and also because it's infinitesimal the
gap opening probability and the
insertion probability and the deletion
probability have got these little delta
t's on them this corresponds to the
length of the time of the instant this
means that these are infinitesimally
small probabilities right because it's
an instant it's an infinitesimal model
it's a
generator right
so so these probabilities are going to
you know be near zero but crucially
they've got this delta t which sort of
will become a dt will become our uh our
um
our infinitesimal sort of derivative
type thing when we start taking limits
so we have a generator that can be
written as basically um you know you can
kind of write it as an identity matrix
plus a rate matrix times a delta t
um
or we can kind of think of it as a
matrix exponential relating to this
delta t and that's basically this model
and so you know it's got these
infinitesimal gap opening probabilities
but they're non-infinitesimal extension
probabilities because once you've
started a gap
then you have a geometric length
distribution for how big that gap is
and so what we're going to do and what
we we do uh so i do do it some great
length in a paper but i'm going to skip
through it now is we basically think
that to imagine that we've got this
model here
which this i mentioned first of all
which is our three state model that
describes a finite amount of time t
right so these transition probabilities
should all be parameters of this amount
of time we expect them to be changing
over time right so when you start when
you start with t0 you don't expect to
see any gaps so all the gap
probabilities will be zero
as time goes on as t increases you start
to see more and more probabilities of
gaps in your alignment
and the way that these parameters change
should be determined essentially by
what's happening in every instant of
time
so what we do in order to model this is
we say well let's suppose that we've got
this model representing time t
and this model representing the action
of a further delta t an increment in
that time that's infinitesimally small
so we multiply these models together in
the sense that we can define more
precisely
then we will get a model that describes
what's happening at time
t plus delta t
that is an infinitesimal amount further
on
and when we do multiply these two models
together we can do it we can define that
multiplication in such a way that is
analogous to matrix multiplication in a
very precise way it's isomorphic to
matrix multiplication
but it's also you can think of it as a
cartesian product of the machines right
this is a state machine that takes an
input and output sequence this is
another state machine that takes an
input and output sequence we can feed
the output of this machine into the
input of this machine when multiplying
them together we multiply a three-state
machine by another three-state machine
that gives us a nine-state machine with
a spaghetti mess of transitions all of
these transitions are sort of the
products of
transitions of this machine and
transitions of this machine
so now we've got a machine with a nine
by nine transition matrix that
represents times t plus delta t and this
incidentally is why we can't just keep
assuming that an exact solution is going
to be offered by this machine for all
types of models because every time you
add an instant time you're kind of
compounding the number of states and
transitions like this but what we're
going to try and do is squash it back
down and so this is really like another
trip from physics that you see quite a
lot sort of a coarse graining or
renormalization idea we're basically
saying that we have this nine-state
machine
with its nine by nine transition matrix
but we want to approximate it to the
closest possible fit that we can get
with a three-state machine and so in
order to do that we basically want to
match the moments and this is where
nicole demayo's idea comes in and it's
equivalent essentially to thinking like
we're running the bam welsh algorithm
for those of you know pair hmms
in every instant of time and basically
saying that but we're going to keep the
transition probabilities here to the
best maximum likelihood fit of this
larger model here
so we can do that
precisely uh in a sense that we can sort
of define algebraically but by thinking
about the expected number of transitions
on various parts through this machine
which you can calculate exactly just
with a little bit of matrix algebra on
the transition matrix of this machine so
we can say for example in any tour from
the match state back to the match state
what's the expected number of
transitions from
an eye type state to another eye type
state in this machine when i'm talking
about types of states i'm basically
talking about the colorations of states
in this machine here this large machine
because when we've multiplied these
machines together we get a whole bunch
effectively of different types of insert
states insert states in which you know
a descendant residue was inserted during
our original
f machine or an insert state in which a
residue was inserted during that later
instant of time you know so there are
various different combinations but they
all kind of effectively amount to the
same kind of state we're going to
collapse them all down into the same
kind of state and so we can just do that
essentially by defining equivalence
classes of states in this nine-state
machine and kind of collapsing them back
down into the corresponding states in
this three-state sheet
so we do that uh and we basically
calculate the expected number of
transitions in various ways we max them
out we we match them up
and in doing so uh we can effectively
defy derive differential equations for
how the transition probabilities of this
machine evolve
uh and basically what we're saying
is that this
we're going to take this product of
machines f and g
and approximate them uh with with a sort
of a
machine f that whose parameters evolve
over time so basically deriving an
infinite decimal limit for the way these
transition counts of various summary
statistics and these parts evolve over
time
and we can just do this symbolically in
sort of
in quite quite a compact space and then
let mathematica do the work of deriving
these equations essentially that's what
we did and then with a little bit of
rearrangement uh we can end up with
actually quite a compact set of
differential equations
uh some of these results are due to
nicola de mayo's work um
but then essentially
the gist of what i'm showing here i
realize there's quite a lot crammed onto
this slide is that we have a free state
machine for derived for defining a
pairwise alignment between an ancestor
and descendant
this way i've defined it here has no
start or end states in this machine so
it sort of assumes that the sequences
are of infinite length we can make a
correction to that by adding in start
and end states with some extra
transitions
but just thinking about the main nine
transitions in this machine
these are probabilities that are going
to be changing over time as the ancestor
and descendant get further and apart
and so we can write down these nine
probabilities as a transition matrix
we can relate them to summary statistics
these big t's which are the expected
number of times we see certain
transitions in these parts on average
and also these w's which are the
expected number amount of time you enter
each state in total
um turns out due to nicola de mayo that
you can actually solve for the w's
exactly
the t's then give you get a bunch of
differential equations i mean in theory
you would have nine differential
equations but various identities allow
you to collapse this down to four
differential equations which you can
then solve numerically i don't i don't
have a closed solution to these
differential equations
i don't know if it's possible to do say
they look simple but that's as simple as
i can get them and there's actually kind
of a lot of ratios and weird stuff going
on in there that's too normally for me
to solve if anyone wants to take a crack
of it please go
um
what we do is use runge-kutta or some
other numerical approximation but i will
say those those numerical approximations
are pretty good now
right you can
using things like runge-kutta and
various sort of you know
things in that family you can come up
with some close form expressions
that will give you the gap probabilities
for this alignment algorithm
and that's pretty cool because that
means that you can plug them into
automatic differentiation frameworks and
fit them automatically to alignment data
right something that people are doing in
the machine learning literature a fair
bit now
uh so you know in theory we can now
get
the upshot of all of this we can get
more precise estimates
of uh of indel rates
um i think that that should pay off i
think that it should give us some better
insight into how frequently different
insertions and deletions are occurring i
still think there's a fair bit of way to
go what we would really like to have
are estimates of indel rates for example
that are
locally varying based on the context in
the protein sequence i mean since i'm
daydreaming
let's say that they should also
be informed by the number of contacts
that each amino acid acid has with other
amino acids in the same sequence you
know maybe they could be connected to
pots models somehow or these various
other methods that people are using to
model protein evolution now
um but i think this is one small step in
that direction i'll just show you that
the results are as you might expect they
are slightly better fit
so these are the relative entropies
under various different simulation
conditions a wide range of time values
and parameter values of all of the
various different approaches that people
have used
including the
barley5 model this rs07 which is
actually quite far off uh the true
distribution
um the the nikola de mayo is one of
these these orange dots and and the
model that i just derived for you here
or sort of pretended to arrive at these
these green triangles
but we're a better fit um we're still
not at zero uh these these these plots
show the relative entropy of the actual
distribution of that length compared to
to what we see
um you know we had a perfect fit we'd be
down at zero
these are all approximations so um but
we're getting closer and i think that
this is uh something that we can then
use to to build more realistic intel
models so with that i will thank you uh
for your attention and uh also to the
graduate students and undergrads who
contributed to this work jolly so
wrestling ryan in particular should have
died
and uh um annabelle lodge has just
joined the group that mentioned her here
but she's working on these problems as
well uh various undergrads who've
contributed and funding agencies funded
it thank you very much
thank you questions
sorry
thanks so much for that release
interesting talk can you go back to the
slide where you show that relative
entropy
yeah so i'm just gonna say this seems to
be suggesting that the
um red lane suchard model is inadequate
so wouldn't you be arguing that the
problem is the model rather than the
other things i mean doesn't this suggest
that the model was the problem well i
said i had a vested interest in saying
the model was a problem i definitely
think it's a problem i don't know if
it's the biggest problem
so yeah
so i understand you're trying to get a
more accurate gap penalty so to speak
um for different regions of the protein
and
does that affect like secondary
structures like loops you were
mentioning earlier did you take those
into account or you just think the model
is going to
somehow implicitly
resolve those
right um that's a great question so i
would say that what we're doing is
analogous in some ways to developing
something like the general time
reversible model for substitutions that
people use in in nucleotide alignments
and clearly that model conflates a whole
bunch of different contexts and into
sort of one model
um and so you know you could criticize
it on those
grounds i think that'd be fair i would
say that i think that then there's ways
you can amend that model or modify it to
make it more realistic you can put in
some latent information that describes
the secondary structure context
and perhaps try and imagine a model that
incorporates interactions with other
regions of the sequence
um
and yeah and so uh in a sense i think
that it's a step towards those but i
agree that's that's right
i have a related question like um you
know all these are for protein sequences
obviously um
how applicable are they to say aligning
genomic sequences oh yeah no i think it
goes well for both um you know i think
um so this there's then issues that you
would want to address um
i mean implicit in this for example is
the idea that there's a geometric length
distribution on the inserted sequence i
think actually we see much longer we see
longer tails even in proteins but we see
really long tails in
genomes we also see very specific
inbuilt sequences such as what leo did
with um caspi where there's for example
uh insertions of big transposon
sequences you know we might want to
actually amend the model to allow for
that so yeah i think there's a bunch of
different
things that you could you could amend
for genomes
hey can you clarify if this is also
modeling the substitution process or
would that be a next step to combine
those oh yeah sure i didn't i didn't
really um talk about that but that's
very good an important question you can
overlay a substitution process on this
and in fact
uh
this whole class of models has assumed
that those are somewhat orthogonal
process but they are specifically
orthogonal that you can just kind of
think of the the alignment likelihood as
being factorizable into an indel
likelihood and substitution likelihood
that once you know where the matches are
then each one
of those is just a substitution model
and of course that assumes that those
are independent processes and that you
don't for example have
a neighbor-dependent substitution going
on or or
or you know any of these covariant
models that are based on contacts
between different amino acids and so on
um so those would all break this to some
extent and you know to different extents
and
um again i think that you know there may
be ways to get to those um or more
systematic variational approximations
that we can do some kind
um but yeah
that you can you can this pair hmm
basically has matched states that are
substitution matrices
and once you're in match you have used
the usual substitution exactly these
processes are interacting that's still
an unsolved
problem questions
okay thank you very much
[Applause]
we reconvene at one third